[Music]
[Music]
after we made contact with the engineers
the Prometheus was destroyed all hands
were lost but I escaped with Elizabeth
one of their ships I was badly injured
on our mission she put me back together
I'd never experienced such compassion
certainly not from mr. Weyland or from
any human
Green's right right through
it's meant to be simple I'm doing my
best
you're very kind at heart you know
we were able to activate their ship and
set course for their whole world
we were finally going to meet our
creators how long
impossible to say what if they're not
better than us so long as they are no
worse
sleep tight
I'll wake you when we arrive
and then I was alone again
I learned of their ways and awaited our
arrival
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
look on my wife's you've all sacrificed
so much to be here and be a part of this
thing we're doing this NGO is made up of
couples it's the first-ever large-scale
colonization mission and everyone back
on earth is really grateful for your
hard work your courage
we're making history here
this is weaved well they ought to find a
human vegetation this far from Earth who
plan on it you hear that what nothing
no birds no animals nothing what
happened here
[Music]
[Music]
what's happening
oh this to start our new life
where is it
[Music]
holy
it's the first ever large-scale
colonization mission and everyone back
on earth is really grateful for your
hard work